la signature d'une charte qualité réseau
entre le département l'association des
maires et la société orange s'est
déroulée dans l'hémicycle du palais de
la source
une collaboration entre ces trois
acteurs concernant l'entretien et la
maintenance préventive sur l'ensemble de
l'île de la boucle locale cuivre partie
du réseau téléphonique située entre les
répartiteurs et les abonnés bien ça va
apporter que ce réseau cuivre qui sert à
tout le monde
eh bien nous allons orange continuer à
l'améliorer et surtout lorsqu'il ya un
incident est ici il ya parfois des
tempêtes et bien l'initiative comprend
qui est une première en france et
d'ailleurs la réunion est un des
premiers départements à bénéficier de
cette initiative va nous permettre
d'agir plus vite lorsqu'il y aura un des
gars sur le réseau eh bien on pourrait
intervenir plus vite
en gros on gagne casse pour cent
d'efficacité et ce quoi que si
l'efficacité pour orange
mais c'est évidemment d'efficacité pour
tout les réunionnaises et réunionnais le
département a la charge d'un réseau de
plus de 700 km de routes départementales
sur lequel les services de la
collectivité peuvent constater des
dégâts au niveau des infrastructures
téléphoniques
cette charte facilitera le signalement
des incidents pour le bénéfice de tous
les clients
d'abord il faut dire que la réunion a
fait de gros efforts en matière de
couverture que ce soit sur la fibre anti
ou sur des réseaux cuivre et c'est une
convention qui fera que avec orange
les élus pourront intervenir dès qu'il y
aura une défection quelconque pour bien
des difficultés liées à des risques de
fortes pluies sur un poteau qui tombe et
c'est donc à un direct pour la
réparation pour l'entretien également de
tous ces réseaux
la société orange propose aux
collectivités un outil accessible sur
internet permettant de signaler les
dommages réseaux et de suivre
l'avancement du traitement effectué il
sert également d' espace commun
d'informations sur l'état du réseau
je pense que en matière de réactivité où
ça beaucoup plus puis rapide puisque là
nous avons une possibilité à partir d'un
smartphone de pouvoir relever le numéro
auto défaillants en matière de télécoms
et puis tout de suite intervenir faire
faire en sorte que en transmettant sa à
orange les l'intervention rapide plus
efficace que ce qui se fait actuellement
où parfois on a beau appeler et cetera
on tombe des numéros et ça
l'intervention ne se fait pas alors que
là avec cette application sera beaucoup
plus au coeur du problème et je pense
que orange réunion ça plus à même de
pouvoir répondre rapidement et faire m
technique chaque année orange investit
500 millions d'euros dans le réseau
cuivre
il s'agit pour la société de déployer
sur tous les territoires des solutions
adaptées offrant la meilleure qualité de
service à ses clients